♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IMPEACHMENT IS
SUDDENLY ON THE TOP OF CONGRESS'
AGENDA SO WHO BETTER TO TALK TO
ABOUT THAT THAN THE FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NEWT GINGRICH?
HE WAS AT THE CENTER OF THE
BILL CLINTON IMPEACHMENT SAGA
MORE THAN 20 YEARS AGO, HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I'M SORRY COME AFTER YOU.
>> I THINK THERE ARE HUGE
DIFFERENCES FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF THE DEMOCRATS, THIS IS A
REALLY BAD DECISION.
GIVEN OUR OWN EXPERIENCE, WE HAD
A MUCH STRONGER HAND IN AN
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL REPORT THAT
SAID CLINTON WAS GUILTY ON
NUMEROUS COUNTS INCLUDING
FELONIES -- WHAT THEY ARE DOING
NOW MAKES NO SENSE AT ALL AND I
THINK WILL PROBABLY POLITICALLY
BE VERY DAMAGING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE WAY IT
SEEMS TO LESSER POLITICAL MINDS
LIKE MINE, IT'S HARD TO SEE WHY
THEY ARE DOING THIS BUT THEY
ARE.
THEY'VE CLEARLY THOUGHT IT
THROUGH TO SOME EXTENT, NOT ALL
OF THEM ARE STUPID.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE REASONING
IS HERE?
>> I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU
GET INTO A ROOM, SURROUNDED BY
YOUR PARTISANS, YOU ONLY LISTEN
TO YOURSELF.
YOU ONLY LISTEN TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE SENDING YOU MONEY.
THE LEFT WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAKES UP
EVERY MORNING AND SAYS WE KNOW
DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE SOMETHING
TERRIBLE, I WONDER WHAT IT IS,
THE MOMENTUM, THE MORALE, THE
EXCITEMENT AND EVERY SINGLE
STORY BECOMES THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY, THE NEXT
BREAKTHROUGH.
THIS ONE VERGES ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" IN BEING
PATHETIC.
NANCY PELOSI WHO WAS NORMALLY A
VERY SMART, SHREWD, TOUGH
PROFESSIONAL GOES RUNNING OUT TO
HOLD A PRESS CONFERENCE WHEN SHE
HAS NOT READ THE TRANSCRIPT.
SHE HAS NOT INTERVIEWED THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER, SHE
HAS NO IDEA WHAT THE FACTS ARE.
IT'S THE MOMENTUM EMOTIONALLY OF
WHERE THEY ARE AT.
I THINK IT'S VERY HARD FOR THEM
TO BACK OFF OF A VERY BASIC
REALITY WHICH YOU KNOW AND
YOU'VE COVERED, I'VE SEEN YOU
TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT IT
BRILLIANTLY -- THEY HATE TRUMP.
THEY GET UP IN THE MORNING AND
THEY GO I KNOW HE'S DONE
SOMETHING TERRIBLE, WHAT IS IT?
BY THE WAY, THIS IS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FULLY AS
MUCH AS IT IS AOC OR
NANCY PELOSI OR WHATEVER.
WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK IS THEY
GOT OVERLY EXCITED, THEY DECIDED
TO DO SOMETHING TRULY STUPID AND
I'VE SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN, I
THINK WHAT PELOSI HAS DONE IS
DESTROYED BIDEN'S CANDIDACY
BECAUSE SHE IS GOING TO BRING SO
MUCH ATTENTION TO HUNTER BIDEN
AND UKRAINE AND HUNTER BIND IN
CHINA AND I DON'T THINK
JOE BIDEN CAN SURVIVE IT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU HAD A LOT OF TIME TO THINK
ABOUT THIS AND YOU ARE ONE OF
THE WORLD'S EXPERTS ON THE
POLITICAL EFFECTS OF IMPEACHMEN
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE'S NOT MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY DONE THIS, YOU'RE ONE
OF THEM.
WHAT IS THE ADVICE YOU WOULD
GIVE FOR THE LESSONS YOU LEARNED
FROM THAT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE TO
REMEMBER?
AS THEY PROCEED ON THEIR OWN
IMPEACHMENT PATH.
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING, I LOOK
BACK ON MISTAKES WE MADE DURING
THAT PERIOD.
I REMEMBER JIMMY BRESLIN WROTE A
BOOK CALLED HOW THE GOOD GUYS
FINALLY WON, IT WAS ABOUT TIP
O'NEILL AND THE WATERGATE CRISI
CRISIS.
O'NEILL WAS SMARTER THAN EITHER
NANCY PELOSI OR NEWT GINGRICH
BECAUSE O'NEILL SAID I'M NOT
GOING TO BE OUT FRONT, I DON'T
WANT IT TO BE PARTISAN.
IF IT'S PARTISAN, IT'S DEAD.
O'NEILL WAS VERY PATIENT, VERY
SLOW, AND GUARANTEED THAT IT
BECAME A BIPARTISAN PROJECT IN
1973.
I WAS NOT ABLE TO DO THAT FOR A
LOT OF REASONS AND I FRANKLY, MY
HAT IS OFF TO TIP O'NEILL
BECAUSE HE GOT IT BETTER THAN I
DID.
PELOSI IS IN WORSE SHAPE THAN I
AM IN.
I WAS UNDER THE PRESSURE THAT
WHEN THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
REPORT CAME OUT, IT SAID
BILL CLINTON AS GUILTY AS THIS,
HE IS GUILTY OF THIS, SEVEN
PLACES WHERE THEY SAID HE'S
GUILTY.
WE HAVE NO PLACE FOR ANYBODY
INDEPENDENTLY HAS SAID
DONALD TRUMP IS GUILTY OF
ANYTHING.
FURTHERMORE IN 1998, WHERE HE
HAD COMMITTED A FELONY OR HE WAS
STRIPPED OF HIS LICENSE TO
PRACTICE LAW IN ARKANSAS, HE DID
HAVE TO PAY A HUGE AMOUNT TO THE
WOMAN THAT HE HAD ASSAULTED, PUT
ALL THAT TO ONE SIDE.
WE NEVER HAD THE SITUATION WHERE
OUR PARTY'S FRONT RUNNER IN THIS
CASE VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
HAS A DOUBLE VULNERABILITY IN
BOTH UKRAINE AND CHINA AND WHAT
PELOSI IS DOING IS SHE'S
ELEVATING PUBLIC ATTENTION AND
RAPIDLY THEY'RE GOING TO GO PAST
TRUMP TO FOCUS ON BIDEN AND I
THINK IT'S GOING TO DESTROY HIS
CANDIDACY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN AMAZING
FACT, THIS IS THE 25TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA.
YOU HAVE A FOX NATION SPECIAL
LOOKING BACK AT IT, THE FIRST
EPISODE LAUNCHES TONIGHT.
TELL US WHAT THE SPECIAL IS LIK
LIKE?
>> LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL I WAS
AT DINNER TONIGHT WITH TWO YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WERE BORN THAT YEAR
AND I WAS SITTING THERE TALKING
TO 225-YEAR-OLDS REALIZING THIS
WAS 25 YEARS AGO WE DID THIS.
I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE BIG
LESSONS AND PEOPLE WHO WATCH THE
SPECIAL OR GO TO FOX NATION TO
WATCH THE FULL PACKAGE WILL
LEARN A LOT.
FIRST, IT ENDED A 40 YEAR
PERIOD, 40 YEARS IN WHICH THE
DEMOCRATS WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
HOUSE.
SECOND, IT PROVED YOU COULD
ACTUALLY HAVE AN IDEA ORIENTED
BIG PROPOSAL, THE CONTRACT HAD
WELFARE REFORM, TAX CUTS,
BALANCE THE BUDGET, A LOT OF
IDEAS THAT WERE REAL THAT COULD
WORK, AND THIRD, COURAGEOUS
TEAMWORK MATTERS.
I THINK YOU SEE PEOPLE WERE
THERE AT THE TIME MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVED
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY KNEW AFTER 40 YEARS THIS
WAS UPHILL AND ALL OF THE
POPULAR OPINION WAS THAT IT WAS
HOPELESS, WE WEREN'T GOING TO
MAKE IT, YOU COULDN'T IMAGINE
IT, EVEN AS LATE AS THE WEEKEND
BEFORE THE ELECTION, NOBODY IN
THE NEWS MEDIA THOUGHT WE'D WIN.
THE FACT WAS WE BROKE A 40 YEAR
TRADITION OF DEMOCRATIC CONTROL
AND IT HAS CHANGED POWER IN
WASHINGTON DRAMATICALLY.
WE GOT MAJOR REFORMS.
>> Tucker: I'LL NEVER FORGET,